Apparently, being locked in a lifelong struggle
between the dark and light sides of the Force
is really good for your pecs.
There are plenty of shocking moments in Star
Wars: The Last Jedi, but one of the most unexpected
occurs when Adam Driver, playing erstwhile
villain Kylo Ren, appears shirtless for no
apparent reason.
It may not seem like much, but residents of
the Star Wars galaxy rarely show much skin,
except of course of that one time Leia was
forced to wear a metal bikini in Return of
the Jedi.
And we all know how that worked out.
So why did writer-director Rian Johnson make
such a bold, beefcakey choice?
In The Last Jedi, Supreme Leader Snoke creates
a Force-driven connection between Kylo Ren
and Rey.
Their minds are combined into the same consciousness
and they're suddenly able to see and hear
each other without actually being in the same
space, an incredible feat matched only by
the supernatural force known as FaceTime.
It's during one of those mind melds that Rey
catches Kylo Ren shirtless.
"I'd rather not do this right now," she says.
"Yeah, me too," he replies.
If it happened on an episode of The Big Bang
Theory, there would be a laugh track.
"Howard, listen."
"No it's your Millenium Falcon.
You and Chewbacca can do whatever you want
to do.
Me and Princess Leia will find some other
way to spend the evening."
But since nothing in Star Wars happens by
accident - except Boba Fett being eaten by
the Sarlacc - it turns out Kylo is half-naked
for a reason.
Sound supervisor Ren Klyce told The Huffington
Post that Kylo Ren is shirtless to prove to
the audience that Rey can actually see him.
"The way in which [director Rian Johnson]
decided to create the Force connection [was]
by just simply doing vertical cuts without
using any CG… it's pure simplicity in terms
of filmmaking with visual cuts.
We cut to her side; we cut to Kylo Ren; we
cut to her; and back and forth.
[Kylo Ren being shirtless] was important to
establish what she was actually seeing.
Was she hearing his voice or seeing his face
or just his eyes?
And so that [shirtless scene] is to inform
the audience, 'Oh, she can see his body…
it's also good humor."
Editor Bob Ducsay reiterated that the moment
serves a purpose.
"Over the course of those sequences, you come
to understand all the rules of [the Force
connection].
Ultimately, it's just good storytelling if
the audience is learning things the same time
the characters they're following are, instead
of ahead or behind."
So there's a perfectly rational reason for
the wardrobe choice.
The question now is, how much does the First
Order charge for gym memberships?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!